to what is going on
is calling up bad behavior yeah i'm
behaving poorly then i'd like to know as
well so yeah exactly i'm seeing the
effects and the repercussions in society
of how you know if people behave in a
certain way with impunity then that
you're going to push the limits and i
feel like we're getting to a stage where
as as soon as a man opens his mouth to
discuss a woman anything to do what
women do oh yeah you're ripped to shred
straight away even on tick tock you know
one girl is saying why is it that on
every podcast you know men are always
talking about women that's it well
there's only two of us here it's a topic
of conversation that needs to be had so
let's discuss and talk about it yeah
and then men with mics that's what they
always be saying well the men use
podcast as therapy to talk a little bit
yeah yeah we have educated conversations
we quote stats and figures and articles
that we read in order to learn and come
to conclusions about what we think
i'm not going to sit here and take your
opinion as fact because the truth is not
relative yeah you know the truth is
objective and this is what we're doing
we're telling the truth
so i'm curious from the ladies do you
think men should have a say in abortion
or do you think it's my womb my opinion
my body my choice no they should because
if they think that they want to keep the
child then they should be able to like
and she's just not about it really so
you think if
if i want to get an abortion and the
person i'm say dating doesn't want me to
he should be able to veto it
it's a tricky one but like going back to
what you said earlier in it like if they
want the child like why should you take
their life away if someone is willing to
bring that child up in a happy
environment why should you
get rid of it yeah it's quite selfish
isn't it yeah yeah yeah no i i agree
with you i'm just surprised it seems
like your opinion flipped a lot oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm kind of educated guys
yeah
okay i'm gonna read some super chats um
okay i'm gonna start from the top
the zap a great show pearl but if the
death penalty deterrence was effective
the usa would have a lower murder rate
than canada with no death penalty that's
actually a good point
william the point i made is that it's
funny to me that scientists say they
find life on other planets when they're
literally talking about frozen microbes
yet we can't figure out when life begins
in children oh that's a good that's a
good that's a good why that's a good
thing
yes sir pgop but what about the
abortions that weren't reported before
it was publicly funded i think abortions
will happen regardless if it's free or
not i think having it free just adds us
a safer way to do it
dude what do you guys think about that
so having it free is a safer way to do
it well it's going to happen anyway so
yeah i will do it for free because
it's it well damage like you're talking
to that oh sorry that's damage if you
think about it because if you're so
you're talking about free to the public
right or is it just free in general free
in general
okay
come back to me if if you're so
driven to have the abortion that you do
it yourself
do what you've got to do type things
like if you're going to do that but
yourself crazy but with what we're
trying to do there's two separate
conversations here like
when it's free people abuse that it
becomes a service that people can use
willingly and freely i agree and that
that's where you draw the line if you if
you if you're so desperate after
abortion and you have your reasons
i don't know what the answer to that is
but
having it be free no because again it
gives people the opportunity to to make
mistakes that shouldn't be made
yeah yeah i was going to say that as
well because you could also say
people are people are going to
actually i was going to say people are
going to murder anyway so why don't we
just not take away the penalty yeah but
i don't think that's a really good
argument to be honest because i was
thinking it's not free no but it's yeah
yeah i get what you're trying to say but
just because you know that people are
going to do it anyway like people are
going to steal anyway so should we just
not have any laws
right of course we should we should
always try to deter things that
um have negative impacts on society um
whether or not people are going to do it
i have no control but at least there's
there's processes in place to prevent
these negative things from happening
um okay so another super chat is i don't
know if the panel knows about the black
woman youtuber who went on a rant
telling black women to abort black men's
babies while being the mother of a black
man herself they hate black men that
much in the u.s
james espinosa the conspiracy is real
feminism is gender socialism the
socialists have spent over 100 years
infiltrating our cultures we are in the
cold war crazy guy women can abort a
child should oh that's the same one as
earlier let me just refresh it because i
think i saw one more
um
okay
free free isn't free it's the tax
taxpayers who pay for it even those who
disagree with it government coercion i
actually agree with that because but we
all agreed that we don't think it should
be publicly funded yes it really
shouldn't
um and then it's just selfish that
people think it's okay to do
okay so let's say let's say
end of the show everyone's pro-life okay
okay okay i don't know how you cannot be
with these reasoning skills
i'm not going to pat myself on
okay okay do you think women should be
tried if they have an abortion
sorry so let's say abortion's illegal
okay
and it's 2022 they said you know what
this is barbaric let's make it illegal
and a girl goes out and gets an abortion
anyway if we believe that abortion
begins at life that's a child so that's
murder
should we try the women that get
abortions 110 because at that point
based on the law it is murder so
therefore you've committed that crime
and you should be tried um justly for
that if you did the crime you've got to
do the time
i don't know i'm really like iffy about
that one because like
murder has always been
illegal so
but abortion never hasn't always been
illegal so it would only be going
forward because at least in the us you
can't
try someone for a crime if it wasn't a
crime at the time
so it would be like moving forward if a
girl chooses to get an abortion
yeah yeah yeah i guess yeah yeah
actually quickly going back here but why
did you choose to because then obviously
there's circumstances such as group
such as grip yeah i'm just going to use
great but the thing is we're saying
tried we're not saying like she's going
to get
like so she she has a chance to like
make her case okay
you know given the if that was the
lawyer she should be tried okay then
yeah yeah well even with grape like i
think if it's it's either a baby or it's
not a baby if it's a baby there's no i
i'm sorry it's a horrible situation yeah
but
if if you genuinely believe it's a child
then that's murder yeah yeah he's still
murder
and the argument like
and i think a lot of conservatives will
say okay we'll give them great because
98 of abortions aren't
so i think because that's always the
emotional appeal that liberals tend to
do is though as they'll use the extreme
in order to justify all of it
so
um
yeah so we agree on that if they should
be tried i think everyone said yeah yeah
okay wow this is like the most i've
never had a panel where everyone ever
agrees yeah yeah
i'll be the calmest panda that you've
had
yeah
because i was like everyone not even one
person disagree
nah fall out i feel like we all got in
there yeah yeah you know what though i
think we came into the conversation with
slightly different opinions yeah and
they all kind of merged as the
conversation went because you can't deny
the facts and i think
to the
for someone to disagree with just to be
out of pure ignorance because again
we've laid out the facts
we've we've articulated in a way that's
understandable so for you to go against
what we're saying it's like you're just
crazy at this point you're sick but
there's people like that because
obviously there's a whole oh no i've
told these facts i've had an abortion
show before yeah yeah okay it went very
differently yeah
there's a lot of crazy people out there
that you know don't ignore the facts for
that for like the two percent right and
that we always maintain that the
exception to the rule doesn't make the
rule therefore we're not going to live
by exceptions
well and it's interesting because when
you literally hear the pro-choice
arguments it's always it's always
they're they're too poor so then
you're putting their value at less yeah
and but that's again that comes from a
place of ignorance because if you look
at places like africa and i do believe
that you know children are a consequence
of of of poor situations right um
because that tends to happen you know
you have poor and
you know less educated people who come
together and kids will be a consequence
of that
but that doesn't make anybody your life
is all equal you know doesn't make your
life worse or less plus
people come out of these situations and
make something of themselves and that's
often the story you know from from ranks
to riches so if it for you to stop that
there's zero logic to understand how
someone could be against or can make
that case it makes zero sense well and
it's interesting because um like my mom
was in i don't know i think some of you
may have heard this story before but my
mom got pregnant when she was 17 by my
dad and they ended up giving that kid up
for adoption
and he ended up like growing up and he
he's really successful now he's just got
married he's i think he has a baby on
the
yeah greg greg's having a baby
congratulations
congratulations yeah
but they gave him up for adoption and
like they ended up getting married later
and having nine more kids
and then adopting three other kids later
and so when i saw that i realized that
you can get pregnant and be in a bad
situation and still come out on top
and do more because now she's adopted
three kids that right essentially could
have had and now they've all gonna have
good lives yeah so and we also got
reunited with greg later i was just
about to ask that yeah yeah no i know
no he um
yeah we like hang out with him now i
found i didn't know he existed till i
was 21 it was kind of weird but
so i could see from that that
even if something bad happens something
great can still come out of it but a lot
of women they think their lives are over
if they have a kid when it could be the
best thing that's ever happened to you
yeah yeah you never actually know you
know that is true
like it all depends on your scenario in
your living scenario than